[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a escala en París una
emisión de radio Francia internacional
en colaboración con la televisión France
24 en español donde cada semana damos la
palabra a personas del mundo de las
ciencias de las artes de la cultura los
deportes la política y claro está de la
sociedad civil París y Francia toda
descubren en estos días las novedades de
los festivales de otoño en los que es
posible disfrutar de espectáculos
venidos de todo el mundo el castillo de
Versalles a las afueras de París será
precisamente escenario de uno de esos
grandes eventos la ópera eco y nazis eco
y Narciso será interpretada en la ópera
Royal del Castillo mundialmente selibre
con ese motivo recibimos hoy en esta
escala en París a Adriana González
soprano de origen guatemalteco y que
justamente interpretará el papel de eco
en esa ópera Adriana bienvenida a esta
escala en París Muchísimas gracias Un
placer tenerla con nosotros es la
primera vez que usted se presentará en
el castillo de Versalles pero no es la
primera vez que está en Francia de hecho
una buena parte de su carrera el hecho
aquí en Francia y concretamente en París
correcto correcto Usted llega en 2013
cuéntenos un poco esa experiencia
Adriana Bueno yo llego a Francia gracias
a el que ahora es mi mentor principal y
colega
primordial iñaki encina oyón que es un
director de Orquesta Vasco y él me
escuchó en un coro mundial de jóvenes
que reúne 65 jóvenes de todo el mundo y
jóvenes entre 16 y 25 años
iñaki me escuchó y dijo Bueno niña
Tienes una voz interesante que quieres
hacer con tu vida yo a los 19 años decía
ay Quiero cantar Mimí Entonces
con eso pues ya él me explicó un poco
más sobre los opera estudios que existen
en el mundo y la formación de un
cantante de ópera después de eso me
invitó a hacer una producción en París y
Bueno aquí estamos varios años más tarde
muy bien Quién es eco Adriana a ver eco
viene de la mitología griega y hay una
leyenda no de Narciso que es la palabra
que todos conocemos ahora el narcisismo
que haber Narciso es el chico que se
enamora de sí mismo de su reflejo en el
agua y eco está enamorada de Narciso en
la historia de Glock porque es un poco
diferente a la mitología griega tenemos
a Apolo perdón
el que ha creado esta ópera precisamente
Y entonces
está eco mi personaje y Narciso
los cuales quieren estar juntos Pero
Apolo el Dios está enamorado de eco
Entonces él les hace de la vida
imposible para que no puedan estar
juntos
es una de las voces más complicadas
precisamente para lograr en términos de
la ópera en el caso de las mujeres Cómo
es que usted descubrió ese don Porque
además a una cierta edad la mujer como
el hombre tienen tendencia a cambiar de
tono Exacto Para mí fue en realidad todo
en el colegio porque no podía
encontrar algún interés en realidad en
en las matemáticas los números y todo
eso para mí siempre fue las humanidades
lo que me llamaba la atención la
historia El arte de la filosofía la
música y fue en el colegio donde empezó
toda ese amor por el canto pero el amor
a la ópera empezó en realidad en 2009
Cuando empecé mis primeras clases de
canto entonces fueras Fue bastante tarde
en mi vida y al mismo tiempo a una edad
relativamente temprana después de decir
así para el mundo de la ópera bastante
temprano exactamente ahora bien su
carrera como cantante yo diría ha
avanzado a un ritmo en Do sostenido
mayor es decir visto la lista de
galardones que usted ha obtenido en
Europa notablemente pues es Ni más ni
menos que bastante sorprendente
sorprendente yo recuerdo Usted viaja a
chipre después es cuando llega acá y yo
quisiera para que ustedes aprecien el
papel que juega Adriana la
interpretación que juega a Adriana les
invito a que compartan como compartan
con ustedes un extracto de la actuación
de la ópera Romeo y Julieta de uno
acompañada por la Houston ópera Royal
[Música]
bien Perdón era la Houston gran ópera
Adriana uno de los principales desafíos
que tiene un intérprete de ópera en este
caso usted es lo que yo llamaría habitar
al personaje que se está interpretando y
además cuando se juega tan diversos
personajes a cada vez con más y usted
para cambiar de piel si se puede decir
en cada interpretación Pues en realidad
la preparación de un cantante de ópera
para un rol empieza años antes no es una
cuestión de semanas ni de meses ni de
pocos días entonces hay una gran
preparación una investigación que se
hace sobre el personaje la historia si
Existe alguna obra literaria y después
por supuesto existe toda la preparación
técnica vocal musical para encontrar los
colores
analizar psicológicamente que queremos
decir todo viene de regreso al texto a
través de un sonido bello y potente
entonces a través de años analizamos un
personaje para Juliette realmente fue
una no sea fue muy fácil abordar este
personaje Porque existe muchísima
literatura
de este personaje no con Shakespeare y
después tantísimas versiones que se han
hecho en el teatro en en películas en la
literatura en la ópera incluso existen
varias óperas de Romeo y Julieta
Entonces eso lo ayuda mucho a uno a
formar un personaje la voz se educa se
cultiva se entretiene Cuántas horas
práctica usted ensayo usted por día
sabiendo que además tiene una carga de
trabajo práctico Exacto
primordialmente trato de cantar al 100%
de mi capacidad
unas dos horas diarias no más de eso
Porque queremos mantener la voz fresca
es como un atleta tiene que mantener los
músculos frescos para poder dar lo mejor
de Sí en ese momento de altísima calidad
después existen muchísimo trabajo que
podemos hacer
fundamentalmente de tomar una decisión
como interpretar el personaje Y por
supuesto que ahora ha cambiado mi tipo
de práctica porque técnicamente ya he
desarrollado a lo largo de mínimo 15
años una técnica sólida que me ha
permitido de encontrar estos colores
fácilmente cuando uno empieza por
supuesto que la necesidad de practicar
al 100% es mucho más pero
saludablemente no debería de ser más de
tres horas diarias
puccini hacen parte del catálogo de
grandes autores que usted ha
interpretado a los personajes que ellos
crearon que usted ha interpretado cuál
sería el personaje ideal para usted
esto cambia mucho con con la ópera la
obra que estoy haciendo en ese momento
porque por ejemplo yo nunca pensé que
iba a cantar roles como liu en turandot
o Mimi en y ya lo he hecho ahora es un
sueño hecho realidad Entonces eso para
mí ya es algo a apreciar mucho Después
Hay tantas tantas obras magníficas tengo
que decir que contesta también en las
bodas de Fígaro es un rol que he
disfrutado muchísimo sobre todo por el
trabajo en equipo que existe en todas
las óperas de Mozart hemos hablado
evidentemente de su participación en las
óperas Pero hay otra faceta de su vida
como intérprete y yo quisiera que el
público disfrute ahora de otra de sus
interpretaciones will you be Mind de la
canción del español Isaac albéniz
acompañada al piano de iñaki encina
escuchenlo por favor
[Música]
Esto hace parte de su segundo trabajo
discográfico que nos puede decir a este
propósito cambia completamente de la
ópera ciertamente
sí y no porque de hecho la técnica para
cantar ópera y lead es la misma lo que
cambia es las sutileza del texto y
cuánto texto decimos en realidad en la
ópera podemos decir las mismas palabras
durante seis minutos en un área y en una
canción en un líder una melodía podemos
decir 40 palabras en seis minutos
Entonces Esa es la gran diferencia entre
ópera y lead pero para mí es un proyecto
muy personal hacer lista hacer la
canción porque
es algo muy íntimo y aparte que el
repertorio que hemos escogido con mi
compañero iñaki es bastante desconocido
Entonces nos da muchísima libertad
artística
Adriana decíamos usted se va a presentar
el castillo de Versalles para aquellos
que puedan venir los invitamos a que
vayan a acompañar a Adriana González en
eco en Narciso Pero además se va a
quedar usted en noviembre también habrá
representaciones en la ópera bastilla
Exacto también
estaré presentandome el 30 de noviembre
y el 3 de diciembre en la ópera bastía
interpretando el rol de Micaela en la
ópera Carmen device una de las más
grandes en todo caso que se han
interpretado más en el mundo el tiempo
se nos va Adriana Yo quisiera
preguntarle a usted visitado algún país
se ha presentado en alguna de las
capitales latinoamericanas eso estén muy
conocida en Europa pero en las capitales
latinoamericanas continente que trabaja
poco Lamentablemente la ópera pues
teníamos un recital planificado en el
teatro de Bellas Artes en México el año
de la pandemia desgraciadamente no lo
hemos logrado recalindarizado
y después También estamos platicando con
la ópera de chile en Santiago de Chile
para organizar un concierto allá y en
Argentina también pero por supuesto que
todo eso toma tiempo con tantos
galardones en su haber con tantas
visitas En diversas capitales europeas
Cuál es su anhelo ahora
eventualmente Tokio Nueva York hablemos
cuáles son sus perspectivas ahora en
realidad la responsabilidad que existe
ya en este momento de mantener un alto
nivel es suficiente entonces con que
logre mantener una bosana a lo largo del
resto de mi carrera que espero que sea
muy larga estoy contenta con eso ese es
el objetivo del momento decíamos ese es
un objetivo de usted ahora volvamos al
caso de América Latina qué es lo que
usted piensa que le falta América Latina
precisamente para alimentarse de esta
savia de voz tan sabrosa tan deliciosa
Tan suave que es la ópera
bueno
es algo que tengo
analizado desde hace mucho tiempo Y
lamentablemente en Guatemala existen
mucha pobreza y por ejemplo cuando uno
está pensando en que le voy a dar de
comer a mis hijos Al día siguiente es
muy difícil pensar Bueno voy a ir a
comprar un ticket para ver un concierto
no entonces creo que toda esa polémica
social económica educativa y también de
seguridad tiene que ser resuelta antes
de que podamos darnos el lujo de pensar
Ah Mira qué bonita la historia que
estamos viendo de todos los sueños
cumplidos en la ópera
aparte de eso creo que existe una
necesidad muy grande de educar en
Latinoamérica porque hay muchísimas
voces fantásticas en Latinoamérica en
todo el continente americano que
necesitan una plataforma educativa y
después laboral para poder desarrollar
su talento pues Adriana González le
deseamos pleno éxito en su presentación
en el castillo de Versalles y desde
finales de año en la ópera bastilla de
París llegamos ya al final de esta
escala en París Gracias por habernos
acompañado muchas gracias a ustedes a
ustedes les damos una nueva cita la
próxima semana aquí en otra escala en
París
[Música]